[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of awesome comics I am your host this
week
Trevor Muller well happy Halloween and
welcome to the show today we are all
dressed up as other characters so when
we do our introductions we will
introduce ourselves as well as who we
are dressed up as but before we get
started want to reminds you guys to like
our Facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome comics show as well as our
YouTube channel that said again I'm
Trevor Muller for this week and today
we're talking about the Adam West Burt
Ward Batman also known as Batman 66 I am
dressed up as Lex Luthor from the Batman
V Superman movie I don't have any Jolly
Ranchers but Sheree the table we have
the people here that think that Batman
66 does not suck go ahead and introduce
yourselves I am Liz Lemon and this is
one of my best friends
vote no 2012 Hillary excellent and on
this side we've got the opposing side
who think that Batman 66 is no good go
ahead and introduce yourselves guys I'm
Norman Bates I'm will Mac doesn't matter
we talk excellent so today we are going
to be talking about one of the first
Batman shows that I ever watched when I
was growing up long before the Tim
Burton movies came out long before
Batman the Animated Series but we
obviously have two very different
opposing viewpoints here and we're gonna
crank it down into three categories the
first one that we are gonna talk about
guys is the cast of Batman 66 right you
can talk about the actors you can talk
about the rogues gallery
whatever it is we'll go ahead and start
on the opposing side here and say guys
why does the cast suck okay I'll start
okay so Adam West look I like Adam West
I respect him I think it's adorable I
think it's so cute that he thinks he's
still Batman that's true but he comes
out swinging
suckas um but the show was meant to make
fun of Batman that was the whole point
of the show it was like the the producer
William Dozier had never watched our
never read any comic books before and he
looked at the Batman comics like but
there's no way we can do this unless we
make it really can't be in stupid and
that's what happened so Adam West is the
poster child for this show obviously
because he's Bruce Wayne Batman
it sort of epitomizes everything that's
also kind of bad about it like I said
before I like him I love him in the
furtherance of Cat Man all that stuff
hilarious I really like animalist as a
guy just as Batman but when people say
she's my Batman like well you are just
like all these tropes we had about the
Batman and Robin the Batman and Robin
like there auto-erotic there's always
been a like you stigma around those two
but then this show with they're so campy
and they're so just weird together that
it just I think that this show really
further that thought it's so much so
that it's been people have thought about
it for years and decades into regular
comics about whether or not what type of
relationship they have and it was such a
big thing and I just I feel like this
this totally moved that forward in the
area negative way right I mean people do
make comparisons that that's not my
exact point but you know I'll back you
up because we're on the same team
Ward I mean you know as Robin
I mean Uzi was pretty young on the show
came out like sound like oh he's a
terrible actor he was what like 15 17 so
I'm like that when that show came out so
I mean I'm not gonna like totally win
blast him or anything like that but holy
Batman our show sucks
I mean good lord I'm good besides him
okay burgess Meredith has the penguin
can we talk a little bit about that I
love burgess Meredith oh yeah big rock
you Sam
you know that's nice this job that
rocket came out because he's known as
Mickey for the most part upon a culture
because he was loved to be known as
penguin that would have totally been a
disservice for him because burgess
Meredith was one of the greatest actors
of his generation his great character
actor if you want to see some great
birds narratives go back and watch a
couple Twilight Zone episodes because he
was in about four of those and he was
great in all those as a really good
actor and I think it's unfortunate that
people still Cesar Romero the Joker's
personalities I get it okay that's fine
that's just kind of that's kind of the
joke I get it Frank Gorshin as the
Riddler event he's off the wall he kind
of reminds me of like a more of a joker
type character laughs is kind of way
very much and whatever transgressions he
was in much of the characters they never
really Batgirl they never really fleshed
out those characters and I think
underutilize they're just there's a hey
look this is pretty girl okay okay so
opposing side why is the cast good you
already said it yourself that the whole
show was meant to be campy so they match
they match this is we let you talk
they match their performances to the
tone of the show which shows their
versatility as an actor you like
off-the-wall colorful and bam pow like
super duper psychedelic sixties and like
not permit every 100% is like the role
that they're trying to encompass like uh
Batgirl Yvonne Craig when she's drowning
in caviar different work but she's just
like in this bag of caviar fun to watch
right does not mean stupid right in life
you were saying it it shows that they
are great actors because they just
commit to the role commit to the
direction and don't question it and just
do what needs to be done to make the
whole theme and feel of the show come
together and like you even said you like
have argued our point for us because
you've already said how many great
actors they have as a part of the cast
let's talk about Cesar Romero here
really quick Joker was just refusing to
shave his mustache with someone being
like nah this is what gets the ladies so
you better kick on that clown makeup cuz
ya goin know
Arisa where his watch that you can see
is not like an actor that was really
good
it's hard to like come out of nowhere
with like this this role that's talked
about for years and years and years and
he goes for it and whether or not you
find it annoying you remember it and you
came up with an iconic laugh like Heath
Ledger's Joker now has an iconoclast I
think to me that is that Penguin sound
that I speak of is his annoying
I'll beat annoying laugh right I love it
and that side way is talking like
characters from the show in the movie
that you kind of remember mom like
visually speaking that costume wise and
look wise he's one of those that pops
right to my also compliment Newmar
changed the way the cat woman was
portrayed in the comics she originally
was wasn't wearing like a cat suit her
body suits or anything and yes super
sexy but but DC had shoved her as a
character because they were like nah
she's nothing but sex we're not gonna
worry about her comic book-y so if it
wasn't for the show's movie that
wouldn't probably wouldn't be right now
great great points made by both sides
we're gonna move on to our second topic
here
you can't talk about Batman without
talking about the gadgets right Batman's
got about everything and this shell I
think took that to the nth degree so
let's talk about you know the gadgets
the vehicles the computers in the
Batcave we'll start with the side why it
doesn't suck
talk about Batman's gadgets in this show
well again it fits the tone it's meant
to be campy and what's more campy than
having shark repellent spray exactly and
I love some of the creeps to be put
forth in some of them though even like I
can't get every time they go down and
there's the instant costume one of them
whatever you want might as well dress
this the time to like if you watch old
Star Trek it's kind of the same way
where some things don't age well because
of the technology of the time and what
was available and they're fluctuating
budget on the show but that was a big
one building UFOs sure you know so it
really has to do with the technology and
where it was in time but I think a lot
of it because they just committed to
being campy and committed to like having
just really cool back gadgets that were
like sure he has this random thing
absolutely he's prepared for all
situations for all situations like yeah
of course he has like a like a pill in
his utility belt they're playing hey
know if you do this it's cool I already
took the pill I already thought of it
you know yeah I think too it's also one
of the most iconic Batmobiles talk about
the Batmobile first I get like it still
looks awesome
oh yes but yeah although all the all the
bat vehicles yeah specifically that
Batmobile great the design is simple yet
still cool and very memorable you still
see lots of people who are try to
recreate that car just because it left
that much of an impact really really out
there random gadgets created all of them
exists now not everyone had a computer
in their homes or the batcaves back then
now we kind of see a lot of this stuff
is like okay well we own all this so
it's just like the newest technology
back then these things didn't exist and
they like created it out of thin air so
gentlemen opposing arguments for the
gadgets freaking bat shield he's got it
folds no Batman doesn't need best shield
okay no no no it's there's so many
ridiculous gadgets that they're just to
throw out there there's just like okay
we're getting away from Batman we're
just trying to throw in as much as
possible to make it just can't be weird
they go away from Batman and they just
throw all the stuff in there just to be
ridiculous I gotta use the most random
ridiculous thing ever to get out of it
it's just like they're not focusing on
Batman they're focusing on what type of
gadget over-the-top what you talking
about the whole iconic all this stuff is
it's like oh yeah its iconic but only
because it's been it's been freaking
forever since this stuff happened and
people still remember it that doesn't
mean it's good its iconic but that's
right it's just because something is
memorable doesn't mean it's good it
might be a bad reason
it is okay that Sonic and good right but
it's not so there's this thing called
the truth control backtester listen to
that yeah it's placed over the face of
the individual being interrogated as the
person answers questions their breath is
captured in the of the bag the breath is
then mixed with a chemical liquid should
the individual be telling the truth the
oxygen content will turn the liquid red
if they are aligned their increased
metabolism means more oxygen which will
create an imbalance in the liquid know
how much pcp those guys memorable and
great yeah yeah the the gadgets are a
big part of the show to cool if you read
the comic always around the city with
with a roof with a little bad at the end
probably not the best way to go I do
think the grapples with back wrap or
whatever they call it does kind of cool
in the show because it flips out so
they're it's not completely useless but
I mean I think we can all agree and I
think anyone at channel awesome can
totally agree that the worst gadget for
a Batman was not from Batman 66 oh here
we go
it was
I can't argue that bad I'm 66 heavily
influenced Batman and Robin which is one
of the worst things of all time so we've
tackled on the gadgets right let's talk
about our final topic here right lasting
appeal is this the kind of thing that's
gonna be remembered for generations has
it stood the test of time is this Batman
or is this a good introductory Batman
for generations today we'll start with
the the nose okay does it stand the test
of time absolutely not that's I think
the one thing that it doesn't do is
stand the test of time you could say
it's goofy campy and I grew up with it
that's great but if you show this to a
kid right now they're gonna be like
where is uh you know Christian Bale yeah
man that I know I mean like there are
kids versions of Batman they're out
there Batman the grave in the bowl is a
great like cartoon show that had sort of
an influence from this that's also yeah
it's a little campy but they actually
throw authentic character stuff in there
there's an episode called the Knights of
tomorrow which is about Damian Wayne
from from that show and they show like
in the future what happens and there's
some really emotional moments in there
and they're not doing it just to say oh
this is this stupid like Batman 66 does
they actually throw some real tension
and real character dramatic tension not
bull crap character development you know
there was none of that you know they
just fight crime yeah I fight crime
honey Catwoman I steal I'm penguin
they're one-dimensional characters and
there's nothing to them so every you can
jump in at any episode and you just see
Batman's gonna save the day so first
story was supposed to be a more serious
thing I mean if I can appear if I will
to the George Reeves 1950 Superman show
the Adventures of Superman
that wasn't like a goofy kind of camp
show but it still was trying to be
something inspiring to kids was true the
character
this isn't Batman folks no okay this
isn't famine no matter how much they
want to try and make it look like the
dark and gritty Batman with the
different covers and stuff it's oh it's
a red sky this is this is the Batman you
know it's dark at me absolutely it's not
okay I feel like they never showcase
Batman's intelligence ever he he has all
these random really weird
rationalizations in the way he gets to
certain things it's just like okay I
guess you can get there from just he
never seemed very intelligence and he
didn't seem like a detective I never got
that yes they go a goofy way about like
some of the like but I disagree on the
detective stuff that's why he has his
whole Batcave and the computers and like
all these tests and things and still
like figure things out so I come like
wholeheartedly disagree on the
standpoint that it doesn't show off that
man's intelligence I think it completely
does and a lot of the times he'll even
give Robin credit for figuring things
out which is like awesome also speaking
of Superman Superman comics for doing so
much better than Batman before the show
in the movie there because of the show
in the movies sales of the comics sky
Rochester so we may not have that it
wasn't for this honestly because they're
just a lot of the characters weren't
doing well in the comics so they shell
with them a lot of the comics themselves
just weren't doing well but because of
the show in this movie we we now have
Batman also Irish I really watched the
movie last night which I haven't seen
since I was really really young and so I
agree that maybe for kids of this day
this is maybe I don't know because I'm
not a kid I can't really say it maybe
this isn't the best Batman to show them
first I think Batman the Animated Series
one is probably more relatable for kids
I think we can for the most part agree
on that but when I was a kid yes I
thought some of the lines for ridiculous
and I was like wait how do you figure
out
they were there that was silly but I was
watching the fight sequences in the
movie where I like completely black like
blocked out of my brain that fight
sequence where he's holding the cat for
like a whole fight seated on a boat and
I was like care to care what's the count
oh my god so fun and ridiculous there's
in the show the dr. cassandra episode
where she's like with the arch villains
and they all go invisible I think they'd
like to take a pill or something I don't
remember but they're all invisible and
the dynamic trio has to fight a bunch of
invisible people and it's just a
soundstage of them off camera being
thrown at stuff and running around and
like dodging stuff and just trying to
look like Fight Club it out with them so
memorable and so fun just so fun to
watch and so as long lasting from me of
a show I would say that has lasting
appeal for me from like a nostalgia
standpoint I mean okay one of the great
things there are narcotic characters
like Batman is that you can have
multiple interpretations there is not
like one and all be all of that I mean I
guess you could argue that but it's
great to see different people's
interpretations of these characters and
that's where we've read things about
comics in general that you have these
iconic characters and different people
come in and have different
interpretations and different viewpoints
of these characters so yes this may not
be dark gritty Christian Bale Batman but
this is a whole different Batman you
just have to recognize that you can't
compare the two
head on at all times they're completely
different tones and totally different
interpretations of a same character
someone - it's my idea of a man dressing
up as a bat fighting other people that
play dress-up and and fun like I watched
it with my parents who watched it when
they were kids and I still this is this
is a teacher side note I guess I still
today
today use some clips of the show to
teach onomatopoeias when I teach English
because it's what that's what it is it's
all the great amount of he's like man
whatever and my kids love it they're
like so like as long as you don't use it
as long as you just prepare people for
like yeah it's ridiculous it's fun
just enjoy it sure people can you can
enjoy both yes yeah you can have both
you can't great arguments on both sides
guys with our last minute here you know
let's let's definitely tell people where
they can find us online and also leave
us in the car comment down below and let
us know what do you think about Batman
66 where can they find you guys online
start here alright you can find me on
Twitter and Facebook and you can find me
on Twitter at Heather ruse or Instagram
at a truce
find me on Twitter at awesome underscore
Walter go ahead and follow me on their
Facebook calm slash awesome and Porter
and I also run a nice little quaint
motel you guys want you can find me
online Trevor a Mueller comm Twitter
Facebook YouTube all Trevor a Mueller
thank you guys so much for joining us
and leave us comments down below thanks
guys
[Music]
[Applause]